Thank you all for being here.
And let's begin. So first off,
Judith,
we just want to start with that with
beginning with what exactly is an empath.
If you could speak upon that.
That's what I just want to say,
how excited I am to be here.
The energy here is so incredible.
It's so beautiful.
And I as an empath,
I'm an emotional sponge and I tend to
absorb other people's emotions or even
physical symptoms or the energy,
a place and to my own body.
But when it's an and when it's like this,
it's sort of true pleasure.
I know it's a beautiful work environment.
So I'm very grateful to be here.
I'm a psychiatrist in Santa
Monica and I'm also an empath.
And so I combine traditional psychiatric
skills with my ability to intuit what's
going on in the environment
and being an empath,
somebody who is very sensitive,
very intuitive, very open,
but they tend to take on the stress of
the world because they don't have the
same filters that other people have.
Um,
and so I feel everything now,
which can be a plus and a minus.
And so I wanted to write the empath
survival guide to give people skills,
how not to absorb the stress of others.
You know,
particularly in the work environment.
If you're next to people,
perhaps you're uncomfortable with how
to just hold the space for them but not
take it on because [inaudible] take
it on and as a result, you know,
I can get exhausted or what I was a child,
I couldn't go into shopping.
Malls are crowded places because I go
in fine and then I walk out with an ache
or pain or anxiety or exhaustion that I
didn't have before and I didn't realize
then as a little girl that I was picking
up the energy and the emotions of other
people, that the whole phenomena of
emotional contagion that can happen,
that we know so much now that for
instance, if you're in a children's ward,
a baby ward in the hospital,
if one baby starts crying,
the rest of them start crying in.
Or if you're in a work environment and
somebody you know has very negative
energy and as a down or it can spread
to the rest of the people like a virus.
And so as an empath,
that's particularly intense.
And so I want to say that the, this
is a gift and we need to learn how to,
to manage it as well.
So I think you sort of answered part
of my second question or the second
question that we've put together,
but it was how did you become involved
in studying empathy and then because this
group is a very curious
and science minded,
I wondered if you could speak about the
science that has come out about empathy.
Yeah, the science behind
empathy as fascinating. Um,
it's believed that there's a spectrum
of empathy, whereas ordinary empathy,
which is so beautiful,
this where you can feel something for
someone else as they're going through it,
but you don't actually take
it on in your own body.
So up higher on the spectrum or the highly
sensitive people who have sensitivity
to light sound noise like to be alone,
like to be in nature,
a replenish themselves by themselves
rather than in crowds of people are going
to parties.
And then on the high end is the MPA impath
who absorbs energy from other people
and is extremely empathic and the
science behind it includes mirror neuron
research where it's thought that
with people with extreme empathy,
the mirror neurons, the compassion
neurons of the brain are hyperactive,
where they're just working on over time
where we feel compassion for everything
and everybody and the world.
And it could get to be too much,
but it's thought that the mirror neurons
are really working overtime as compared
to let's say a narcissist or
a sociopath who are thought,
who have empathy deficient disorder,
meaning they don't really
have empathy as we know it.
There are mirror neurons are
thought to be hypoactive,
meaning they're not really
functioning at full tilt.
And then there's the whole
phenomena of emotional contagion,
which I mentioned is that emotions can
be catchy and we are sensitive to how
people are around us.
Their emotions affect us even if
we're not in path that somebody else's
emotions.
If they come into your work environment
and there a drama queen or there are
chronic talker or they're a victim
where they always want to talk about
themselves and their victim status,
it brings you down.
If you're an openhearted person, you know,
if you're open and you feel all this,
your energy goes down,
so it's important to understand emotional
contagion and also the concept of
dopamine or dopamine is the pleasure
hormone and it's thought that impasse need
a smaller amount of dopamine to feel good.
Then let's say extroverts who get their
dopamine fakes from going out, you know,
with big parties and big
events and football games,
and you get a large
dopamine hit with that,
but empaths get satisfied by very
little interaction. For instance,
as an Empath, I love one-to-one
interactions. I really enjoy them.
But when it gets to be a lot of people,
it gets overwhelming.
For me as I love to connect.
And in too many people on a
personal level is hard for me.
I speak to large groups and that's a
bit different. But on a personal level,
I prefer to have small
gatherings and it could be, um,
the dopamine explanation and
research because it just,
I require very little. I get
filled very easily, buy happiness,
and I get drained. If I stay in
a social situation for too long,
it's too much for me because
I get overstimulated and
too much is coming in too
fast with sensory overload. So if you're
an empath or you're a sensitive person,
it's good to look at the science
behind it. I know. And it's,
it's not also the electromagnetic energy
from the heart and the brain gives off
information. And so we're transmitting
information and if you're sensitive,
I'm like, you're an empath.
You can feel all this,
but the problem has empass don't
know how to manage all of this.
And I think if you break down the science
and you begin to look at the various
aspects of the science,
um,
it's very useful in terms of explaining
what you're feeling and why you're
feeling it.
Thank you Judith.
Um,
in relation to some of the things you
have talked about with the science behind
it and some of the terminologies that
you've used with regards to extroverts and
introverts, um, that is a
question sort of that when he,
and I haven't read the book had talked
a lot about because in the book,
and it feels as if you have,
you know,
given your story as an introverted empath,
as some of you may know,
I'm extremely extroverted and I'm so,
I'm more of an extrovert,
empath.
And so could you talk to us a little
bit about these differences in terms of,
you know,
I,
I do love going to parties and I do love
talking to people and being out there
and d and that fills me
up versus if I'm alone,
all the energies that I've picked out
tend to make me really feel just more
alone. I can't get out of the
loop. So can you speak on,
yeah. Um, they're both introverted
and pass an extroverted empath.
I happened to be introverted.
What, what are you,
I am definitely the introverted
type of empath. Yeah.
And Heather is extroverted and
most analysts are introverted,
but some are extroverted. And by
introverted, I mean I like to be alone.
You know, I, I'm a writer and I
liked it to be in my room alone.
I know with my own energy,
just allowing the creative flow to happen.
I enjoy that. That's like the epitome of
my life experience, you know, at that,
at that moment.
But extroverts,
they tend to go out more and I go out,
but I don't go out that much and that's
okay with me. I'd rather be in nature.
I'd rather be in quiet tranquil
environments, um, or one to one.
But you're an extroverted and passed,
so you go out into environments.
But my guess is you need to decompress
afterwards is that, you know,
at some point.
Yeah.
I think one of the things that I sleep
really deeply and I have a feeling that
part of the reason that I
sleep deeply is because I have,
I process it in my sleep versus
out in the about in the world.
And I mean I just felt that,
um,
some of the things in the
book talked about, um,
some things to help an extrovert empath,
if any of you can relate to that is
to meetings with other people who also
experience it because then
you're amongst other people.
Cause that was my big thing is I,
I just,
I can't function to take it all in
and be by myself taking it all in.
Okay.
Well it just varies.
I mean you might identify with various
levels of this and so it just depends how
you process things.
And I just want everyone to know
if you identify with any of this,
you're not neurotic, you're not
crazy. There's nothing wrong with you.
It's a sensitivity level that I
believe is important to develop.
And certainly in massage therapy,
you know,
you're feeling what's
going on in other people.
And so the sensitivity is there. And we
need more empathy in our world today.
You know,
desperately I be in places like
Google to have empathy for each other,
you know,
and to make your work environment really
positive and caring I think is, uh,
a wonderful thing.
And to have empathy for you know,
the world and to bring that in. And it
was something I'm really passionate about.
Thanks Judith.
I feel very privileged to be in this
company because there is such a spirit of
inclusion and respect for diversity.
And I also know that I have, you know, my,
my own characteristics,
um,
where I get frustrated or feel victimized
by things that happened to me and my
day. And so when I was
reading I thought, yeah,
yeah,
I wonder sometimes if I'm
also an energy vampire,
like do I flip between these two things?
What if I'm the source of,
of drain for somebody else?
And how do I reconcile that with,
with also being an empath?
Because once I get through my mood,
um, I'm kind of back to
my, to myself, but I'm,
one of my goals for
this year is meditation.
Okay.
And I've, I've done a good job
and I feel like it's helping me,
but I really don't want to be
that to other people. So how,
how do I work on that?
And how does an empath reconcile also
sometimes being the energy vampire?
Great question. It's a very
humble question actually,
if we can all ask that. Um,
there's a chapter on the book on combating
narcissists and other energy vampires.
And it's important if you're sensitive
to identify who are the drainers,
especially in the work environment,
you can have a lot of different
kinds of drainers. No,
from the drama queen to the chronic
talker, to the narcissist, um,
to the passive aggressive person.
So there are many kinds of
energy vampires and yes,
we can all be drainers.
We can all be energy vampires.
So not to think about is that Oh, them
or him or her. But when we, you know,
get in to are kind of lower
selves and we get, um, no,
our buttons are pushed and we're triggered
and we're tired and we're not in our
best selves, then you know,
we can be victims, you know,
or we can be talkers or we can be,
you know,
just people who will bring others
down and so it, that's okay.
I mean that's part of being human and
it's great to recognize it in yourself.
I mean, that's so great that you
asked that question and you know,
it's wonderful also because
you can catch yourself in a,
with the awareness when you start getting
into those energy vampires states,
you can say, okay, you know,
or if your coworker, you know,
I hope has the freedom to point it out.
You know, it's a little touchy subject,
but to say, you know, I love
you or I, I respect you so much,
I love working with you,
but you're complaining a lot today.
I don't know if you have the freedom
to you.
Yeah,
well Googlers tend to be extremely kind.
Yeah.
There. I'm sure there are conversations
like that, that are done, you know, very,
I don't know what the watch
fully tactfully. Thank you.
I'd say I think that's true. People
here are very kind and have a lot of um,
exhibit a lot of tolerance and attacked
and we always need to work on feeling
like we can, uh, bring up a
challenging situation and,
and discuss it in a nonthreatening
way with people. So yeah,
I hope that that's the case and it
because somebody who is rolling with there
being an energy vampire, it can really
bring down the work environment.
So it's really a toxic influence.
Um,
and so I feel that that
needs to be addressed as you
say it compassionately and
lovingly.
Um,
because sometimes we don't know when we
get into those states and it could just
go on and on and on. And you don't
want that in a work environment.
You optionally want positive
energy in your work environment.
You want it to be easy and fun so your
mind can just go to creative places,
you know, and really envision, you
know, the amazing things for yourself.
And an energy vampire is important to
identify because they could bring it down.
And so to address it, not punitively
but lovingly, you know, I hope I don't,
I hope that there's a way to do that
here and to recognize, you know,
not to get angry at the person,
but that they need understanding
nine,
10 tells money they're an energy vampire.
So,
um,
and moving on with the questions.
Um,
we wanted to ask sort of
related to that a person who,
um,
may be not just in a phase in
that moment as an energy vampire,
but that's their personality.
They're like full on,
complete like a narcissist
or something lacking. Um,
neural plasticity teaches that our brains
neuro circuitry is malleable and the
studies have shown that mindfulness
meditation that includes loving kindness
that you talked about
can rewire the brain.
So is it possible that somebody who
could possibly have a full blown on low
empath, narcissist trait
personality change with that?
Um, it's very hard for
narcissists to change. However,
I just want to say narcissist can be
really creative and productive and have
great ideas and be very intuitive.
So they're,
they're not all negative
in the work environment.
It's just the problem comes in personally
or you interact with that because they
just think of themselves and they don't
really care about what you're feeling
because they lack empathy.
The full blown narcissist now who are
self absorbed and they become cold
withholding and punishing when
you don't do things their way.
So it doesn't make for a
great management style.
It really doesn't. And so, you know,
hopefully they're not too many here,
you know, in terms of narcissist,
because it doesn't foster creativity.
It shuts people off.
It makes people feel small and damaged
and not heard and not listen to. And,
and it's so important. If you're
sensitive and you're an empath, you know,
you care,
you know,
you really care about others and
you don't want to be shut off.
But if you do have narcissist here,
you know,
just take advantage of all their
strengths as nobody's all bad. You know,
the, there's a Buddha and
a demon inside everybody.
It just depends on what we feed. We want
to feed the best parts of ourselves.
I know the most sensitive, the most
loving, the most compassionate, you know,
and then understand that
we can be energy vampires.
Sometimes we can be a get
go through a bad period. Uh,
so I think with a narcissist,
if you look at what they can give to a
work environment and not expect them to
be your best friend,
it's a lot of patients who come to me,
I have narcissistic bosses and that's
really hard because you really have to
frame things in terms of how it will
serve them for them to be on your side.
And it's tedious, Ego stroking
and as hard for sensitive people.
But if you want to have a vacation,
let's say you don't say, I'm so tired,
I really need a break now
they won't give it to you.
But if you say this will
serve the business, um, then
a narcissist was like, oh,
okay, how, and so then it would make
more sense to give you a vacation then.
So ideally you don't have to do that,
but in case you're ever faced with it,
now that's one tactic that will work.
I think that leads really nicely
into the next part of our questions,
which really involve how do we work
with these tendencies in a workplace?
What are some solutions when we're
faced with small personal space,
a lots going on,
lots of distractions and,
and
then we want to,
uh,
be able to be as creative as possible
and work at our highest level.
So what can we do as,
as empaths to foster that?
Alright. Right. Well,
one thing I noticed here, Google
is the high ceilings. I mean,
that helps to have a feeling of
space and it's very beautiful to me.
I feel like I could breathe here. I
don't feel claustrophobic. I don't,
everywhere I look, it's high ceilings.
So I'm not, do you have low ceilings,
other places here? Not so many. No. Yeah.
So that helps with the
feeling of spaciousness. Um,
but in terms of techniques to use,
um,
I really suggest meditation.
There's a four,
a three minute meditation where you can
just check in with yourself for three
minutes, close your eyes,
focus on your heart,
focused on something really positive
in your life and breathe out stress and
focus on the positive.
And during those three minutes you can
recalibrate yourself and you could come
back to your center B as part of the skill
of being an empath and an environment
is learning how to come back.
When you start to swirl or when somebody
pushes your button and you're triggered
or you're disappointed by something,
or if something happens in your personal
life and suddenly you go down, you know,
to recenter yourself through med at this
three minute quick meditation is a a
form of coming back to you that a lot
of people don't know how to do that.
You know, once you swirl,
they just start swirling.
And so learning how to breathe the breath
is very powerful because the breath,
you can breathe out stress and you
can breathe in clarity or calm,
peacefulness.
But to breathe out stress.
The breath actually carries the
stress out of you, out of your body,
which is what you want.
So these regular meditation breaks,
I really suggest,
you know,
to help you feel better and to help
you reconnect with your creativity.
I keep coming back to that
with this audience. Um,
that creativity is so important for you
to be able to really play up here and,
and to play and to feel comfortable.
You have to be in a good environment.
And you mentioned that you have a close
environment and some places that there
are a lot of people in a, in a small
space, lots of people in a small space.
Um,
how much room do you have between you?
I'm not the best person to
speak to that because I used to,
I work in a spacious place. That mushroom.
Okay. All right. That's not much room.
All right. And so you need to
create your own personal space.
At least you have that much of them.
It is an open space environment. Okay.
All right. That's particularly
challenging for sensitive people.
And so you have to make your desk,
your spiritual station and
know your energy station.
However you can be comfortable
there with pictures of people. Um,
I wear the Kleinian around my neck,
who's the goddess of compassion.
If she really sets a tone of compassion.
Um,
sometimes gemstones are important to
put around the desk or whatever is it
centers you. It could be anything. It
doesn't have to be spiritual objects.
It could be anything that you love to
create a circle of safety around your desk
and like a bubble of invisibility, you
know, if you feel like being invisible.
And visualization is
very important for that.
If you have an open space environment
to visualize a protective bubble around
your environment.
And although you see other people and
you hear them talking and they're moving,
you're in your safe place.
And so what you're doing is somebody
in your own inner power to create a
visualization for yourself.
You're not helpless in this environment.
And when you begin to experience that,
you'll feel incredible relief. So then
you can focus. You know, it's, um,
when I learned to meditate,
I learned how to do it in a room
where next store they were having,
it was a Sunday and they were having
meetings, prayer meetings with songs.
And so when I was learning
how to meditate, I had a lot
of external distractions,
which was really helpful for me because
I wa I learned how not to be thrown off.
And that's part of this path of empowering
sensitivity is how do you learn to
center yourself, admits
distraction and chaos. You see?
And so you can look at it as a fun
challenge. And I don't know if, um,
can you hear other people talking next
to you? You can hear them. All right.
Are you allowed to wear earbuds here?
Okay, well sometimes that's helpful. The,
and playing nice music so you can
use, you know, these techniques,
but most important energetically you
want to just focus on your own energy,
your own space,
your own creativity and not on the,
somebody cracking their gum next to you
as empaths are very sensitive to
that, like coughing, cracking of gum,
clearing of the throat. Um, you
know, all that like, you know, just,
it's important to,
to focus on yourself so that you can
screen out external distractions and you
could be in your best place.
So on that note,
talking about the things that
we can do in our workplace. Um,
like one thing that I have told kinds
that I know that they find their peace on
weekends out in nature.
I've told them go, you know,
get a picture of that and put it in your
work space so that when you're feeling
that overwhelmingness and your mind's
just racing and everything's distracting,
you look at that picture to
sort of calm that down. Um,
and on that note, talking about
the different types of impacts,
you do speak of that in your book,
would you like to sort of go
over a few of those for people?
Because once you sort of
recognize this is what I took
away from the book,
what type of empath that you are,
there's going to be different tools,
obviously that will work for you better
than for a different type of empath.
Yeah,
there are different types of impasse
and some impasse or emotional and paths
where you're especially sensitive to
other people's emotions. For instance,
if somebody is angry and they come
into work angry, you take it on. No.
Or if somebody is depressed,
you can be sitting next to somebody and
suddenly your energy is going down and
you're starting to feel a little
depressed and you pick up their emotions.
And so empath are sensitive to emotions
and some are even sensitive to physical
issues where you can pick up,
let's say your coworker has back pain
and suddenly you're back begins to egg.
So it's just something to
watch out for in yourself. Um,
and then there's impact
called intuitive empath.
And these impacts are very
open to their intuition.
Now really tuned into intuition.
I personally feel as a psychiatrist and
an empath that is so vital to listen to
that inner voice and impasse have a,
you know,
a little bit more open than other people,
but everybody can connect
to their intuition.
And that's the still small inner voice
that comes through gut feelings or the
enteric nervous system in the gut has
actual neurotransmitters that convey
information like the brain.
So what's going on in your
gut can convey information.
And so as an intuitive empath,
you can train yourself to listen to
your gut feelings about somebody.
Let's say you're hiring somebody and
they, oh, they look totally good on paper,
they look amazing,
but when you're sitting across from them,
your energy is going down. Now what
is that telling you? You know it.
It could be that this isn't a good match
for your particular environment as you
want to have people who are energetically
harmonious and when you hire people
and when you interview people,
when you're an intuitive empath,
you can develop intuitive skills in
terms of you look at what they present on
paper,
but you also can feel what's going on
in them is these are you listen to your
gut feeling,
you listen to a hunch.
You listened to an Aha knowing that it
can be waves of goosebumps that say,
yes, this person is
right. This is exciting.
This is going to be a great match or you
can, you know, feel a kind of a downward,
the mud, you know, or a wall
or something that's unpleasant.
But when you train yourself as an empath
and as a human being to listen to your
intuition,
it can give you extra information.
And so that's really essential.
But what happens is sometimes people
don't listen to their intuition and they
second guess themselves. You know,
particularly in a very linear environment,
you know, where you're given information
but something doesn't feel right. Um,
I really encourage you to weigh that.
No in your relationship choices and
in how you do with your coworkers.
Because it will tell you, maybe I should
stay away from this coworker today.
Maybe they need a bit more space and
it's a gift to give them that, you know,
and to honor that they seem
to be in their own world.
They seem to want to go into
a cave. All right, fine.
I'll give that to them and I won't talk
to them that much if possible. You see,
so you can really have deep compassion
for your coworkers and for others by
developing this skill of intuition that
many empath having some of the specific
types,
some impasse or animal empath.
I see there's a doggy on
here that's a great, um,
that you're allowed to bring dogs here.
Oh, that's amazing. Being dawn concert,
you are
and,
and pass have a communing with
animals, with dogs, with cats,
with wild animals, you
know, with birds that they,
some feel a very deep
connection to animals. Um,
and some have a deep connection
to the natural world and plants,
they love to have plans. They
love to garden. Um, and some
have of you, as you said,
a connection to their dream life.
And there were some impasse or dreamers
and they could tune in to their dreams
to get guidance in the morning
by remembering your dreams.
So these are all intuitive outlets that
you can really explore and play with,
you know, as a sensitive
person as opposed to being a,
a disembodied head who's just a linear
person who lives up from here up.
Um,
I'm really advocating being your
mind and reasoning and in the body.
I'm listening to your intuition and
your sensitivities as you can be both.
And sometimes, um, there's a
bias against men doing this.
And I have a Facebook empath group and
it's over 11,000 people and it maybe 85%
men, I mean women and 15% men. So no,
it's harder sometimes for men.
I don't know how it is.
So there are a lot of men in this
audience, which is fantastic. Um,
if it's harder to come out and salmon,
intuitive feeling person.
And I'm also really intelligent and
smart and creative and grounded.
So to balance everything for both
men and women who are empath.
So there was one other empath that I
wanted to ask you about and I'm also kind
of looking at time and want to make sure
that we leave some time for people who
have questions out there.
So you had spoken about being in nature,
actually I think it was you,
Heather,
but it came up again when Judith was
speaking and you speak about earthing or,
or write about earthing in your book.
And I often will tell my clients
after their session, you know,
you may want to take a few minutes,
we're close to the beach or find a
patch of grass and take your shoes off.
Stick your feet in it.
Can you speak to how
that helps us?
That's so helps us in so many ways now
to get out in nature and take your shoes
off and go barefoot in the grass.
I go barefoot on the ocean and just feel
yourself what that feels like and just
the freedom and an often reminds
you of how you were as a child,
if you had the opportunity
to be in nature as a child.
And to reclaim that and to just
go play and feel what's coming up.
The electronics change with the earth.
I mean I have very strong feelings
about the earth and preserving our
environments and how we connect to
our environment and how our bodies are
intimately connected to the earth.
So of course we're going to
feel if the earth is harmed.
And so the mission of helping the earth,
these to be number one above all
things as far as I'm concerned. And um,
you know,
it's difficult for impasse in this day
in time with the support of the earth not
really being there and our
social environments, it's
just devastating. You know,
for me, when I hear about certain
ravages of the earth, however, you know,
you can go out and connect.
You'll see people aren't
trained to connect to the earth.
And if you stay in an office for too
long or it's not actually an office is an
open air environment.
But if you stay closed up too long,
if you stay at your computer too long,
you can get kind of sealed off from
the world and you want to connect.
You want to take a break from the
computer and your work and go out.
You're so close to the beach.
You could take a walk and go down to the
ocean and see all the c goals and you
know, get into your child again.
You know, I know you, you know,
you're adults and you work at
Google and you have very, you know,
important jobs and you're,
you know,
you really are playing a
role in bettering the world.
But it's good to also let that
down, you know, and go and play.
You know, if you can't, it's
go and connect to the earth.
And you could lie on the earth.
You could climb a tree,
you could meditate by a tree. No, but,
but to have that playfulness, you know,
not impasse tend to get overly
serious and life is chart.
So you want to have as much playfulness
as you possibly can to remind yourself
of that because you deserve it.
You know,
I kind of live with the philosophy of
this is the day I'm given the eternal now
and I don't know about
tomorrow necessarily.
I know about today and I want
to make it the best possible.
And that isn't just work,
work,
work all the time though I've
always been a workaholic and a,
I've always loved to work. When I
was a little girl, my report card,
the teacher said, you know, I need
to take the pressure off myself.
Like I'm seven years old.
My parents didn't give me that.
I was born that way. And so, you know,
it's important for me to find the
balance because I could get lost in my,
in writing and patients and
what's, you know, face, you know,
in the Internet, you know, going on
Google and googling things all the time.
And so it's important. Dance,
dance is a good way to,
to sort of get your body moving
so you're in your body. Yeah,
yeah. But just moving and, you know,
being in the body as an
important way to balance and, um,
but I just want to acknowledge
the, this environment, you know,
how creative it is and you know,
what an opportunity you have here,
you know, as employees of
Google, um, to really, you know,
create and change the world. It feels
like and changing the world is here.
It just feels so important to be here.
So you brought up children and I know
there's a section in your book about that.
And I,
I guess part of changing the world is
also making sure that we influence our
children to be good human beings as
they impact the world themselves.
So it's so important to support the
sensitivities and our children as they're
going to save the world. And now they
need to be raised in a way where,
you know, you look at them
and you say you're sensitive,
you're open and that's beautiful and
there's nothing to be ashamed of.
And just because you may not want to be
on the football team and you may want to
go into the forest and meditate,
you know,
that makes you unique and beautiful will,
you don't have to fit these children,
these sensitive children
or indigo children is new
children that have a certain
consciousness coming into the world.
You don't want to fit them
into some arbitrary mold.
You want to really help them and support
them. And a lot of times as children,
you might not have been supported, you
know, in your sensitivities or intuition.
And that hurts because I know as an empath
child and I had to physician parents
and 25 physicians in my family,
so I came from this long lineage of
scientific thinkers and I was a feeler.
I would feel things, I would
know things. I would, you know,
process it differently than a
traditionally scientific personal.
Although I did go through medical
school and I conquered, you know,
that to balance both the intuitive
and the, you know, the scientific.
But it wasn't how I was born.
And so I've had to reclaim that
as a psychiatrist and as an adult.
And that's what I'm
inviting you all to do,
is to be as linear as you want
to be as inventive in your minds,
but also,
you know,
reclaim your sensitivity and your
openness and your playfulness and your
connection to the earth.
We can be everything.
Okay.
I love that. Yeah. Shall we surround the,
so we have about 10 minutes or so.
If people have questions,
just go ahead and raise your hand
and we'll be glad to throw you.
Are you good at catching?
I'm not usually,
I mean even that's so creative.
She's through the mic and
a little box over to him.
Um, hi. Uh, I had a question.
I noticed in your bio it mentioned energy
awareness. Um, and through my process,
understanding the human energy system
and how to work with it has been really
valuable for me.
I did it through medical Chigong.
I'm just curious what kind of energy
awareness a little bit. All right.
And just curious what kind of energy
awareness techniques he used in your
practice.
Can you repeat that for me?
And so he wanted to know what kind of
energy awareness techniques that Judith
uses in her practice in. He
found it through, um, I'm sorry.
Was it and she gone,
she gone.
She Gong.
It's a wonderful way to center your
energy as a movement where you center your
energy and you feel the
universal energies in your body.
And that's a beautiful energy technique.
Any,
I mean you could even do a cheek on here,
you know,
to go out somewhere in practice, you
know, here and just do a few movements.
What I use in my practice is that I teach
people to meditate and I also work on
them energetically or I put my hands
over their various shockers to balance it
and teach them to open up their hearts.
Shameless plug. We offer, um, ty gene,
which has Chigong elements in it weekly.
So
yeah, so I, I'm brought in instructor,
we weekly for a,
and you can join us at the,
I'm lax techy group and emails and I in
some Mondays from four 30 to five 30 and
there is a cost because I brought in the
instructor but we meet over in the bin
five courtyard or inside the bunker
when it's called. That's fantastic.
Lot of people who are not
empathetic. Right? Uh,
they might be kind,
they might be changing the world and not,
might not be necessarily now
cystic is there some tool,
some kind of Myers Briggs personality
test kind of thing so that they recognize
that they are not empathic? Yeah, no.
And if there is one and then we know
what do we do with it once we have one,
three,
now the person is not the empathic.
What are the actions
apart from meditation,
can a person take to sort of develop that?
That's a great question. Um, once you,
how do you identify if somebody doesn't
have empathy and then how do you deal
with it? Okay. Um,
the best way is to provoke
a small conflict because
if you provoke a conflict,
you can see how they deal
with it as if they have.
Why are you laughing? Conflict, conflict.
Oh, it'd be really fast for that
little conflict. Let's say they say,
let's meet today at 10. And you
say, well, I can't do it at 10,
but we'll do it at 11. I mean, even just
a little, little thing like that. Um,
somebody who doesn't have empathy is
going to become cold, withholding,
judgmental,
punishing and change.
They're very nice personality
and to a different one.
And so narcissists who don't have empathy,
um,
don't like it when you
don't do things their way.
All right. Have you met
people like that? No,
I just meant to say that an mean maybe
there's another classification out there
which is basically kind people,
not necessarily people,
but they are not empathic.
They have don't have the mirror mirror
neurons as to say they do not understand
what are you going through. So
did you cannot relate to you. Uh,
in general they sympathetic
but not empathic. All right.
They're very kind people that
love data but they are not,
they cannot understand what you're going
through your emotions and will state
this that you come in and you, you look
very sad and you don't want to work.
But let's say as a
manager or somebody else,
but he doesn't recognize that I knew was
thinking why does he not recognize that?
So they are lack empathy.
Just it don't know but they're
trampling over somebody.
Yes. Let me make the
distinction of lacking empathy
versus someone just being in
their heads.
Because sometimes people are self
absorbed or in their heads and they're not
tuning in.
Emotionally happens.
But that doesn't necessarily make them
a narcissist and they could be the
kindest person, but they can also be
out of touch with their feelings. Yes,
exactly. That, that they could be.
When I see a lot of people in general
are very kind to bed on Tinder word,
but when it comes to personal
relationship, because they
are very smart and then,
and brains, right, they did. They don't
tune in today. Empathic centers are,
they not have the Blob tempurpedic center.
So they just relate to to your brain.
Yes, yes. But they're kind people.
They find people didn't want to
harm anybody. They don't want to,
but they do not understand the actions.
In fact,
other human beings.
Okay. Do you, do you find that that's
common? That's common really. Okay.
Well that's, yeah. Not narcissist
necessarily rate. Right. Well,
I mean that leaves an opening on emotional
training and intuitive training for
people here.
You know,
it's something that's really important
to train in a safe environment.
And if that's the case, a lot of
times it's something that think about,
but in terms of your expectations of them,
you could come in with a broken heart
and they probably won't see it. Yeah.
And to not take that personally.
Yeah. Yeah. I understand about it,
but take it a is a, is a way I was,
I was thinking more in terms of uh,
in Myers Briggs test,
you go take an online test and it tells
you what letters you are ENTP I STP,
whichever it might be the
case. So is there an online
test? I can go and say, hey,
you're not empathic.
You is
out one,
230 or 20.
So that we know and we
can say to each other, oh,
we had pointy hundred so we know
each other in some objective way.
I know an objective way.
All right.
And that would be in well and you
would want to pass that around and have
everyone take it.
Yeah, that will be, that will
be the Google way of doing it.
All right.
Well,
I mean there's certainly a self assessment
test at the beginning of this book
with 20 questions that people can take
and determine where they are on the
empathy scale. Um, but you
know, there could be other,
other ways to do it too in terms
of creating more formal um,
tests and scores. But that's,
that's a good idea. Um,
but I think the goal would be really to
help people recognize that that's right.
Yeah.
Cause the more empathy you have,
the better your work environment is
going to be because you're going to feel
safe. You don't want to lose it. You
don't want to overdo it. You know,
cause sometimes impasse can be,
you know,
help too much and they give too much.
They want to be too compassionate and
they're looking at you in the eyes too
deeply so it feels intrusive. You
know, that, that kind of thing.
You don't want to become that, but
you want to become smart, intuitive,
caring and blend it all.
And that takes some training sometimes
to do it and hopefully the book will do
it.
But trainings can help
but proposed you who recognize it.
At least you can narrow that this
person's at least like that. It's okay.
Absolutely.
But you know also to recognize that being
a good person is the best thing anyone
could do. And even though, you know,
they might lack other, you know,
abilities. If you're a good person,
that's a beautiful, beautiful thing.
You know, it really is. So to recognize
that in each other and you know,
to affirm that, you know, Nama stay,
I respect the spirit within you.
I know to be able to say
that to each other even, you
know, with all your faults,
you know, we have tons of faults,
all of us, we're not perfect.
But if we do the best we can
and we're loving people, no,
give people credit where credit is due.
And when you can affirm that and others,
the whole environment in
the work environment can
just increase the vibration,
increased the frequency when you do that,
as opposed to looking at all
the negatives and someone,
it's much easier to look at the negatives,
you know,
and criticize them and
what they're doing wrong.
But the shift in consciousness in terms
of awareness of empathy is trying to see
the best in people you know,
not their worst.
You want to bring out the best in people.
When we talk about empathy,
normally we're talking about
social with other people.
So I thought kind of separate
question a little different.
Here we are.
I'm an engineer.
I think a lots of other engineers
and even Judith yourself,
you are Saudi.
You like to work like writing by yourself.
Sometimes I feel the stress
actually from the work,
not with interacting with other people.
Uh,
when you have something
difficult, something you
don't understand for a while,
especially later of the
day you of tired Rio,
a cognitive capability can,
tends to be done.
And my personal experience sometimes
in that situation I started,
you'd have self doubt and it's
kind of become a downward spiral.
And that's an active energy can I can
bring with me home even though I'm already
out of work, I still think
about it. But maybe after night,
the Max day I look at it again,
I can't figure it out.
It seems so simple.
So what can you suggest to do to prevent,
you know,
just to bring that negative frustration
out of work when you want to not think
about it at that time.
Very good question. How do you not
take the work energy home basically?
And you mentioned self doubt. Yes.
Did you mentioned self doubt? Yep.
Because you know, I can figure this
out. Maybe I was not good enough.
All right,
well I'm a big believer in affirmations
and so it's important to really affirm
every day what you did well.
No.
And at the end of the day you could
make that a ritual to just say,
what did I do well today?
What did I contribute?
And it could be the tiniest thing. It
could be a big thing. It doesn't matter.
But instead of you know,
the self doubt, no one,
I talk about the demon
and the Buddha inside. Um,
the self doubt comes from more
the demons side. You know,
where you have to work with it. Everybody
has self doubt. We all have self doubt.
When you affirm I did this well today,
I did that well today and I brought,
I was breathing today.
I was walking into today, I came to work,
I had a day of life, you know, really,
I mean, you can just get, always get back
to that, you know, to uh, to affirm that.
And also to have a closure meditation
when you are ready to leave work to
actually sit, close your
eyes, breathe center yourself,
say thank you for this opportunity
of work today and now I'm leaving.
And so to have an official ritual of
closure and to let go of what happened at
work and that will help you. I don't,
when I'm finished with my patients, no.
Usually I forget about it. I know
I go onto the next thing, you know,
unless there's something in
particular that I, you know,
that I need to think about a
little bit more. But I go on,
I'm 100% present when I'm working.
Like with here, I'm 100% present,
but when I go on, I want to
grab the next moment, you know,
and inhabit the next moment.
So it's good as a sensitive person to
be present in the moment and then keep
moving. And I was like the warrior,
your make your yell and then you move,
you know,
and that's it.
And so we know that that's to
think about to be in the moment.
And how do you be in the moment now
you can have a mantra even, you know,
let it be no, I'm being
in the now, you know,
and to bring your mind back cause
we have control over our thoughts,
our attitudes and our mind. And so when
we go into self doubt, you'll go, ah,
Sam left out. I know you all right.
Instead I'm going to breathe,
I'm going to focus on my heart and I'm
going to look at what I did well and
let's say I need improvement in something.
I will work on that. And we all,
you know,
are constantly works in progress.
And so to have a lot of compassion
for yourself every day and what you go
through, we all go through
so much. You know, all, you
know, as a psychiatrist, they,
I know well how much we all go through.
And so just,
you know, give people a break,
see the best in them and you know,
try and be empathic for
what they go through,
even if it's not something
maybe you can relate to,
but if you're empathic and your heart
goes out, no, that's a good thing.
It's really a beautiful thing to
relate to one another in that way.
Hello.
I'm kind of along those same lines.
I find what's really emotional draining
for me as being constantly connected, um,
via my phone or social media,
things like that.
Do you find that it's important for,
especially for sensitive people
to have that time to disconnect?
Maybe have a day without their phone,
like is their tips and
tools that you'd recommend?
I think it's important to
have a technology fast, um,
and not go on social media and turn off
your phone and leave your phone at home
and go for a walk on the beach so
that you're not tethered to the phone.
I mean, even in the gym, sometimes I bring
my phone and I put it on the, you know,
the treadmill and I have to talk to
myself. Just leave it in the locker,
tell, bring it, you know, your
world can exist, you know,
for a short period of time
without that phone. But you know,
it's very addictive technology and so
you have to really make that extra effort
to say no to it.
And it makes me feel so much better
when I'm not near anything. You know,
there's a, um, a monastery
that we go to sometimes in the,
in retreat Tassa horror monastery.
They don't even have electricity.
They have no cell phone coverage,
they have no electricity,
kerosene lamps. So you're forced into,
you know, a beautiful retreat of,
you know,
without technology.
So I think that makes you
better when you come to work,
when you have those breaks as if you
keep checking and checking and checking.
It puts you in a Zombie like
state and that's not in the body.
And so to put it down a little
bit and go dance, I think dancing,
you know what you mentioned or movement,
any kind of movement,
the Xi Gong Movement, dancing, walking,
exercising,
looking up at the stars and the sun.
It just replenishing is very
important without technology and just
want to add one thing and that is when
we talked about the children and what
we're teaching our kids
that our future is,
we're teaching them this importance of a,
how much our phones are.
And they will say, what do you
mean you, you, you lost your phone.
What are you going to do?
Like even they as young as
five are picking up on our
attachments to our phones.
So
my daughter,
very worried one night because my husband
went out for a walk and didn't have
his phone. And I thought, oh this,
this is a day without a phone.
I think it's a new g.
Did she class?
And thank you both Heather and Wendy
for half a my hair and thank you all for
coming.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming.